iran's chief nuclear negotiator at the
vienna talks told al jazeera that tehran
had presented its proposals and the
other parties should present theirs
the proposals tabled by iran cannot be
rejected at all because they are based
on the provisions of the 2015 nuclear
agreement and in principle the countries
which are still the participants of the
jcpoa they do not want to ruin the
nuclear document all the sanctions which
have been imposed or reimposed under the
so-called maximum pressure campaign of
the united states they should be removed
immediately
the u.s secretary of state however
painted a bleak picture of what he
suggested was iran in intransigence and
a united international front now we've
had this first round of talks uh since
uh since the new government's in uh and
what we've seen uh
in the last couple of days is that iran
right now does not seem to be serious
we're now in a different place and even
uh russia and china
are clearly frustrated with
what iran is doing or not doing in these
talks however the russian ambassador
appeared relatively unambiguous about
the adjournment there's a technical
break of the vienna talks which will
resume next week he tweeted an
opportunity for each participant
including iran and the u.s to consult
with the capitals and to think how to
proceed further taking into account the
positions of other counterparts
the first week of talks confirmed
predictions that initially both the u.s
and the new iranian government would
take maximalist positions as they sized
each other up it's clear that iran feels
that as it was the u.s who withdrew from
the iranian nuclear deal and then
imposed unilateral sanctions the onus is
on washington to act the u.s feels
differently but there are further
complications now there's another
element which is the uncertainty about
where the united states is going uh and
that is creating even greater problems
because even if sanctions are lifted
today and the deal is revived
european companies are likely not going
to go back into iran until they are
feeling far more confident that the new
situation is a stable one and there the
2024 elections is a major major uh
factor
still it is seen as a positive sign that
the talks will reconvene next week and
there will not be another long hiatus in
diplomacy shia britancy al jazeera
washington